yo what is up everybody procedure man
Luigi here with some Borderlands the
pre-sequel gameplay today I'm gonna be
showing you something really cool I did
not find it however I want to share with
you guys
this is another secret boss most you
guys probably know about your JIRA if
you do not go check out my thingy rocket
launcher guide but in this video I'm
going to be showing you how to farm how
to activate and farm Nell who is a
second boss in this game seconds kind of
secret boss you have to know what to do
to get to him and kill him and get his
legendary so hope you guys enjoy the
video alright so the first thing you're
going to need to do is go to regular
range you can access this by going to
serenity and driving over to where you
go to fight dead lift this is the only
way to get to it because you cannot fast
travel to it you can drive in from the
other side and if you have the skipper
unlocked I think you should be able to
do it that way would probably be quicker
than this way
but I was not sure if you could or not
when I did this so I just did it so you
went I went past dead lifts kill dead
lifts he I haven't finished the game
right now yet so he's still level 30 you
run over here to the doll way station
and you're going to go to the building
on the right for to activate Nell you're
gonna need to find two letters and put
them on a place and they're gonna call
him a dick because there's a side quest
in which for a guy that you die for a
guy that you kill you have to call for a
guy that dies to fulfill his last
request you have to call him a dick it's
called Nell a dick and this I think you
can only unlock this after you do the
mission to do it so it's a little
different than ear Egeria you can't just
hop into it
so you're gonna see uh you're gonna hop
in this building and start parkour and
up it you actually do not need a grenade
jump for this part i think i missclicked
f ya you don't need a grenade job to get
on here the other building that you'll
get the second letter on you will need a
grenade jump but this one is this this
specific jump is kind of hard but you
definitely don't need to see I just got
it eat pretty easily without doing it
even though I failed a few times so
you're going to be picking up a D and a
K I believe here upon this building is
the
the the D and the other building is
going to be decay you see the other
building is just the other tallest
building a kind of parallel to this I
don't know that's the spot we're going
to put it on this building you saw the I
in the C so it's going to spell the i ck
dick and you're going to go over here go
to the side I don't think it'll work in
the other side it can only work from
this side closer to where you come in
from so you're going to hop on these
first couple things you won't need a
grenade jump till you hit this third
object you stand on I don't think you
can do it without grenade jumping so
just D choose deselect your grenade mod
and check your normal grenade at the
ground and it'll and jump at the right
time and it'll burst you up and do you
live jetpack odds get thing and then you
got up one and go to another one this
one make sure you're not standing too
close to the walls you can stand too
close to the wall you'll get knocked to
back by the little overhanging arch so
there also are chests here so if they're
to your level then it's good loop so
you're gonna pick up that however all of
this stuff is leveled around 30 because
I think that's that's the level I was
when I went through this area however
when you activate now he's gonna be
level 50 51 if you're in true vault
hunter mode and also he spawns in a
bunch of scabs that you're gonna have to
kill before he fights you see he's gonna
get mad right now yeah see he's getting
mad but you can't fight him he's gonna
be green just undamaged undamageable
like a normal friendly NPC until you
kill all of the scabs that attack you
and all of the scabs that attack you are
48 to 50 Rayne 51 range so it is tough
fight you see I sped up a little bit of
it this is only like I'd say about half
the fight it is a pretty it's pretty
tough fight I actually got some better
gear later on and I farmed him again and
I just went by so fat so much faster
because I had a laser that you get for
being in the game so you're gonna go
through kill everyone and then Nell will
attack you he is firebase I think he has
a Nova shield and he throws fire
grenades so if you have a fire
impervious shield it should help a lot
he's not too hard of a boss like I have
the shotgun like kill him fairly fast
and you see all just throw fire he's
just big on the fire so you're gonna
just just shoot him he spawns some more
guys when you're
18 him so be on the lookout for that
those get you can get yourself up on
those guys if he downs you XD I'm gettin
I'm gonna get myself self up on the
moonstruck I think I think I'll get
myself about him maybe I won't and then
I like to kill Nell from the beginning
oh wait wait yeah I get myself up nice
so you do that kill Nell and he has a
chance I only know of one thing is a
chance to drop it which is a legendary
sniper rifle that the name is left me at
a blank since I just forget what the
name is however I was really lucky I
didn't get it this first time I killed
him for the video however I went back
one time one time I killed him I got the
legendary sniper and it was level 50
because I killed him at level 50 Sears
right there I just kind of clean up the
rest of the bandits that are there from
when now spawn them and then I'm gonna
go drop something pick up a sniper rifle
it's a pretty good sniper rifle I'm
gonna do a review about it so look for
my look on my channel for the review of
that sniper rifle it's a six shot let's
see what is it called it's called the
schoolmaster the to cope I think is just
the prefect since I have another to cope
sniper rifle that's unique I think it's
just the prefix for the mail it large
melee damage so yeah it's powerful and
it's time six shot so I think it's
pretty good and that's how to farm the
Nell the secret second secret boss and
the legendaries and get a legendary
sniper rifle out of it so hope you guys
have enjoyed this video and hope you
guys can go find Nell and kill him call
him a dick and get a sniper rifle and
make sure you stay on the lookout for
other Borland's the pre-sequel cons and
i'm going to be pronouncing that we'll
be putting out a lot thanks